Chase McCall is a marine safety officer
with the fire department in Long Beach
he just finished washing some trucks
along the beach when someone told him
about a dog in the water the dog was
called tofu and he'd been swept several
hundred yards offshore into the Pacific
so Chase McCall Gunn was paddle board
and wetsuit and rescued the dog he had
helped from another Marine safety
officer called Devin Beebe who guided
McCall to the dog with her binoculars
Chase McCall joins us tonight with the
dog he rescued tofu thank you both ah
thank you both for coming on uh so so
Chase how far out was this dog
I'd say uh tofu is swimming maybe two to
three hundred yards out offshore
what tofu doesn't look like a retrieving
dog for example how did tofu get 300
yards offshore do you know
um I I heard reports from just Beach
patrons that they had been chasing her
around trying to catch her for about an
hour or so in the parking lot and uh oh
wow I guess she just jumped in the water
and and took off towards uh
out to sea
how did she respond when you tried to
pull her onto your paddle board
I think she was grateful to see me there
and a little relieved she looked a
little tired and cold and came right up
to me and made it easy for me to grab
her and put her on the board
so dogs can I mean dogs famously know
how to swim in birth but they can drown
right
oh yes definitely
is this common if you rescued other dogs
from the Pacific
uh we've had a few
um incidences where we've we've rescued
dogs from the water
um yeah so it happens not too often but
it does happen for us what did the
owners say when he brought tofu back
um so we didn't really talk to the owner
until the next day so we uh handed tofu
off to Animal Care Services and through
social media
um the owner was able to get the contact
info on where she was being held and
so the next day when I met the owner
they were really grateful and just uh
everyone was so happy that this this was
a success story
are you a dog lover
I am
I can tell by the way you touched that
dog good for you chase McCall thank you
so much for coming on tonight we
appreciate it yes thank you thank you
for having me
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight